asham à ta voix le contraste entre la
beauté du paysage et les conditions de
vie de cette communauté autochtone et
frappe à la réserve qui n'a pas accès à
l'eau potable qui combat une épidémie de
tuberculose depuis des années doit
maintenant lutter contre une éclosion
fulgurant décote coved 19 dans cette
communauté isolée d'environ 1300
personnes plus du quart de la population
a contracté le virus et le taux de
positivité et d'environ 80% l'anxiété
empêche cette résidente de dormir les
maisons de chez mattawa étant surpeuplé
esther thomas partage la sienne avec
deux autres adultes et neuf enfants
c'est très difficile dit-elle surtout
lorsque vous vivez avec autant d'enfants
depuis le week end une soixantaine de
militaires sont à pied d'oeuvre h à
mattawa leur mission livrer de la
nourriture au résident à aider au
traçage des cas et faciliter les
déplacements vers le centre de dépistage
avec la pandémie
la seule école de la communauté de chats
mattawa est devenu un peu le centre de
commande c'est là où sera en contre par
exemple l'armée comme elle le fait
derrière moi le conseil de bande de la
réserve
les bénévoles les travailleurs de la
croix rouge pour coordonner les étapes à
venir au deuxième étage habituellement
il ya des salles de classe mais ces
salles ont été transformés en unité
d'isolement préventif l'armée entre
autres aider à mettre en place des
unités et on a également établi une zone
rouge dans le gymnase de l'école voyez
donc derrière ces portes interdit d'y
entrer ce sont des résidents de la
communauté déclaré positif à la coved il
n'a pratiquement toute la communauté a
eu un contact avec une personne déclarée
positive explique le chef de la première
nation pour lui
les prochaines semaines seront
difficiles tant et aussi longtemps que
le vaccin n'aura pas franchi les
frontières de la réserve ici patrick
fouques ou radio canada dans la première
nation de chats mattawa au manitoba